the dean show and it's always
it's always exciting being back with you
for another episode of the dean show
and we get people from all across across
the globe and they come in and they
share their story with us
they talk to us and we want to know why
would they accept islam
why would they leave the religion of
their forefathers of their great great
grandfathers or their fathers or their
mothers and accept this way of life
that a lot of times you get a lot of
scrutiny for it you know you might not
get invited to the vip parties anymore
you might not
get that vip card anymore you know what
you might even lose your job
you might even not have the same friends
because they don't want to be friends
with somebody who's a muslim
but you end up gaining a whole new
family of over 1.5
billion and you end up doing something
that brings you peace and happiness
in this life in paradise in the next so
without further ado when we come back
we're going to be talking to justin
and we're going to hear his story on why
he came to this beautiful way of life
islam sit tight we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
peace be with you my brother peace be
with you assalamu alaikum
welcome salaam how's it going
alhamdulillah justin
eddie i'm the dean show my pleasure all
right all right
so you know we're talking about serious
issues here you know we we take a break
from you know
all the other things that are out there
sports football basketball
work and we want to talk about these
serious issues that are in the minds of
the more serious people
because death is a reality we're going
to die and this life is transitory
it's passing it's fleeting so those
people that are tuning in now and
they're
they're they they you know they're
they're sick of just
all the other things that really aren't
of much benefit but this is a benefit
talking about god talking about the
creator
and talking about this way of life that
it just makes sense and
it made sense to you that's why you
became a muslim right so we want to just
talk about your history and then we're
going to come into
why you decided to blonde hair blue eyes
and you're a muslim
you're not an arab you're a muslim
you're american too huh i'm american
i'm a texan oh yeah texas so
uh look talk to us a little about
yourself well i was born into
catholicism and then through my
experience
i looked into that and i became
christian
and well it was a great experience you
know i went to church every sunday and
i prayed every night in the morning in
the evening and i read my bible
and next thing you know i just
i started asking deeper questions and
i never could once find you know where
jesus
peace be upon him said that i am god
or that he was gonna he him saying i'm
gonna die for your sins
so and then at the same time i was 18
19 20 and i was living the life of
that age group i was having fun i was
chasing my desires
and i was sinning and i still felt
guilty
inside my heart and it never made sense
to me
somebody dies for my sins but i still
feel guilty
so then i i got down on my knees and
and deep internally within me i always
knew that there was only one god
and i would always pray god guide me
and thank you for jesus and i never
could understand anytime i talked to my
grandma or my grandpa or somebody in my
family they couldn't fully unders
explain the questions that i had to them
and
so then i mean alhamdulillah that means
all praises to god
this this journey led me to islam and
i'm really excited to share it with how
it came
in islam entered into my heart now if
more people i'm i'm sure we're more
we're open-minded and many are many are
are seeking more substance to life you
know
they made a lot of money some you know
lost the bank account lost a wife lost
the house lost the car
so you know they come to a point they're
like all these material things they're
not just they're not doing it for me or
someone has
all the material things and still it's
not doing it for me so
what made you at what point in your life
were you like okay you just woke up and
like let me just get this bible and
start reading you're in a hotel they're
all in the hotels
did you start you know practicing
christianity be
before uh were you were you
did you have like an epiphany that
something something something happened
in your life that you started to prac
lead
practice because you you were catholic
then you went to christianity so
before that were you just chasing your
desires and then
what led you to want to be a christian
what led me to be a christian was all my
friends i grew up in friendswood texas
and all my friends were christian and
we'd go to church on sunday we go to a
place called
you know like a church camp and and i
like that lifestyle i like the
the group the team the environment
and you know like you said i was that
guy i was always making money and i was
doing well with business i had a house i
had
all the nice toys and then it just
i just still didn't feel that peace
inside my heart and soul
and all praises of god once again some
of my brothers
they started coming to me and saying
justin you've got to check this out
you've got to check this out
and we were having bible studies and we
started asking each other questions and
and it really just took me being
interested and me being sincere
and me searching because if we're
sincere and we're searching and we're
and then on top of that we're trying to
live the right life and staying away
from the you know the bad things
it's called fitna or the trials the bad
things
by me doing the right things and being
sincere
all praises of god he led me to
submitting to him
and islam comes from the word peace
which means peacefully submit
to the creator and if we're gonna
worship something
i figured i might as well worship the
creator instead of any of the creations
yeah that makes sense because jesus
peace be upon him he was the creation of
god we love jesus
i love jesus on my heart yeah but he's
not god right
so we don't want to worship the creation
of god we want to worship who jesus
worshiped
exactly who did adam worship he
worshipped the creator okay who didn't
know it no worship the creator
who did abraham worship the creator who
did moses worship the creator who did
jesus worship he worshipped the one god
and that's
what i'm talking about that's who we
worship muslims worship the creator
because somebody stumped out there you
just they were coming along they were
going along with you
god god then when you said jesus i want
to say who did jesus worship jesus
that don't make sense right and who was
jesus praying to yeah
when jesus was fasting in the desert and
the and the devil came to him
and tempted him does the devil tempt god
does it make sense does god fast
no not at all no so it made perfect
sense to me
jesus was a creation one of the best
prophets ever made
and he worshipped god he submitted to
god he followed the first commandment
just like moses and just like all the
prior prophets they follow the first
commandment
and that's what muslims do follow the
commandments
this is amazing now did you change your
nationality when you became a muslim
no i'm i'm still american yeah and i'm
still got the same color skin
you still say y'all i still say y'all
and i still you know
i go hunting and fishing and yeah i'm
still texting still a good old boy
that's good that's right i'm a good old
boy
but do you eat brownie i love beer honey
yeah and
all the good arab food but how about i
mean what's texan food what
texans like the um you got mexican food
you've got
i mean we don't eat pork chops no more
okay because it says in the bible
you better not eat pork so you know we
follow that so my christian brothers out
there you got to stop eating pork
what's the big change now what's the you
know what's the big deal it's a big deal
to worship
others besides god that's a big deal
i'll put you in a hellfire forever if
you die on that it's a serious matter
right but now what's the big deal for
someone looking out you're just
worshiping god
you know you're not doing anything weird
tell us you know a little bit
uh you know of what your day-to-day
lifestyle is like
well i i wake up in the morning i
purify myself just like the other
prophets did and i then i say my prayers
and then you pray like this uh no i get
down on my hands and knees i put my head
on
on the floor and just like all the
prophets didn't
mention in the bible that's exactly what
they did and then i have a moment to
myself i read
and then i go to work this is what i
love about it
five times a day i take five minutes out
of my day
and pray to the creator and none of the
creations
and i feel a deep internal peace i mean
it's simple
and i still have my normal life i get to
hang out play football play basketball
you know i have a wife come to the law
she's an amazing girl all praises to god
and i feel very blessed we're going to
take a break but it's exciting too that
your wife
she also was a christian she accepted
islam is that correct that's correct
amazing amazing we got so much to talk
about we'll be right back with justin
for more here in the dean show we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Music]
and with good deeds i will find that
good breeds good
clear out your mind and your heart
of hatred
and preconceived notions racism and
nationalism
because you cannot have anything inside
of you
that's like that against people and
still be successful
[Music]
back here on the dean show with my
brother justin
and we left off we're gonna talk about
we got so much to talk about yeah we do
now before we continue on okay
you talked about your your wife okay she
also was a convert she accepted islam
and before i ask you about that tell us
for for the people now
okay you know they're listening and
they can relate they're all so confused
about the trinity about worshiping a man
you know worshiping saints and idols and
you know
hail mary give me ten of these say these
things god forgive you go to the priests
and
confession box these things just you
know god is the one who
created you god's the one you pray to
god's the one who forgives sins
not a man not anything in the creation
but the one god and
this makes sense you know simple logical
but you heard of peter pepe king
you hear that gentlemen they had some
kind of uh
hearings and they were talking about
mosques
the place that you know you go to to put
your face on the ground
the same way you describe jesus putting
his face on the ground and pray to god
right
now what did you experience being as a
muslim now
do you feel because now you're you know
you're you're around muslims
do you feel that islam now is is
something that's promoting violence
that islam is like what you see on tv
that you know it's about you know
radicalization now you're muslim next to
you know
that you're going to be talking about
you know uh gee hi you're going to be
trying to blow up america and blow up
this building and that building and
people are scared now oh a texan you
know you're rough and tough guns in the
west
and now we got one more you know uh
loose cannon right what do you got to
say to those people who are a little
scared
well with without knowledge they're
without lack of knowledge people
obviously tend to be scared like right
when i told my family i became muslim
they were like you became a muslim were
you to go blow up something
they said that they literally said that
at the dinner table when did you convert
to islam
i said actually dad i reverted back to
islam
and like a light bulb went off in the
family's head they're like what do you
mean you reverted back to islam
i said well i was we were all born
worshiping the creator
and none of the creations and i went
back to just worshiping
the creator and they were like
just dumbfounded you should have saw
their faces all praises to god
islam has brought me peace first of all
we're all made out of energy
atoms vibrations and right when i put my
head on the ground for the first time
and did the prayer with my head on the
ground just like jesus did just like
moses did
i i could feel my energy i could feel i
don't know maybe
light i don't i felt i felt peace
that's the best way to describe it and
no it's not islam to attack people to
hurt people to do any of that stuff
that's
that's just what you see that's just
what the tv is going to tell people
they're always going to attack the truth
you know that look at history
you know one with brains one with eyes
to see just study history and they've
always attacked the truth
and what's the truth monotheism what's
monotheism
worshiping one god what's polytheism
worshiping multiple and i choose to only
worship one god
and that's what islam is submitting to
the one god
that's amazing because that's so true
throughout history you'll see that these
mighty messengers that were sent
by god they were calling the people away
from idolatry from paganism away from
that to pure monotheism
and it wasn't easy jesus peace be upon
him he got spit on he got spanked he got
hit
they tried to kill him right right and
he was delivering the truth he was
calling people to worship god
and people were opposed to that yep yeah
so now
you have the last and final messenger
prophet muhammad peace be upon him who's
doing the same misses as jesus and moses
and noah and abraham calling people to
the same
religion the same way submit to god
do god's will and this is what you're
doing islam yeah that's what islam is
calling you to
it's it really is all the prophets it's
simple
they all worship god and jesus peace be
upon him
he worshipped god yeah muhammad peace be
upon him he worshipped god
and that's what muslims do we just
worship god and we do it five times a
day and it feels great
okay good for for the texans and and the
canadians and all the other people
watching us all around the globe
you don't have no bomb here there's no
strapped to them no bob
it's all good as they say in the hood
yeah it's all good in the hood down in
that wood
all right yeah so we know this is silly
islam doesn't teach
any of these things islam is calling
people
to worship the one god and noble
behavior and doing good
right so you went also and you did the
fifth you you've already done that you
established the prayer five times a day
yes and now you also tell us about your
experience you went to hajj
oh man you know in the in the old
testament it says when you go to the
valley of bacca
and to make your pilgrimage so i saw
that but i didn't know how
and that's what i like about islam is it
teaches me the how
well where do i go i went to mecca the
kaaba the central location the heart
chakra of the earth i went there
and i saw one point there was actually
six billion people there i'm sorry
six million people there roughly and
they were white they were black they
were asian
they were from all walks of life rich
they were poor and they were all doing
the same thing
they were all there just to worship god
and they were all there trying to do
good deeds
handing water out giving people dates
giving people
food you know smiling saying peace be
with you
assalamu alaikum peace be with you and
if you look in the bible peace
jesus peace be upon him that's how he
greeted people
peace be with you and that's what islam
is when i went overseas
i saw it firsthand i never i've never in
my life i never was a crier like
i was always mr tough guy growing up in
the society with the culture and the
music and the rap and the movies
and then when islam entered in my heart
my family
my friends they can all sense and feel
the peace that i have and i whenever i
hear
the call to prayer whenever they make a
call to prayer
i cried when i was over there and
whenever somebody beautiful who was
praying
i cried just by hearing it and i i put
the the
the quran in my mom's ear it's like a
prayer on fourth of july
last fourth of july and i said mom how
does this make you feel
and she listened to it and she literally
my mom and my sister both
same night they both started crying just
hearing
god's words from the quran and
it's peace going overseas and seeing
that there's nothing
that compares in my mind and i just wish
and i hope that god will
open up the hearts of everybody to see
and feel what i've felt
being able to go overseas i took my
brother muhammad he's the guy who
kind of said hey he started asking me
the
deeper questions in life what's the
purpose of life where are you going to
go when you die
and i took home all praise of god god
allowed me to take him
because all we are is tools eddie all we
are is tools we're either being deceived
or being guided and all praises of god
that
we've been guided and i was able to take
him and
it's been the best thing that's ever
happened to me tell us in short before
we go to break your wife
also she's a revert to convert she
accepted islam what happened with this
wow this is great
my wife she um she was like a bible
thumper like super jesus freak
and and her friend decided she was going
to become a muslim
and she said to our friend you can't
become a muslim my wife is like no no
you can't become a muslim
and her friend said okay well prove me
why not
so my wife before i even knew this girl
this three years ago
she starts looking into islam and
all praises of god with a sincere heart
god led her to submitting to him alone
and none of the creations she accepted
islam she accepted islam
allah thanks to god we'll be right back
with more here with justin on the dean's
show
don't go
afraid to nowhere alone if allah is by
messiah i am not
afraid to stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
i am not afraid to stand alone if a lie
[Music]
is
back here on the dean show with justin
a texan you were born in texas yeah i
was born in texas
born in texas okay let's just back it up
a little bit for those people
you know the the donnie bravos donnie
brasco's and
you know the the women who are out there
who are you know people who are living
this life of debauchery
you know just really just going from
nightclub to party you know
even even some people get a little more
sophisticated so they might not want to
go to the club but you know
it's just more about the wine tasting
and you know posh lifestyle
and you know pritzy uh uh you know just
the glamour and the glitz and
following all the celebrities and
whatnot you know what
do you do you have a chance to sit now
that you found the truth
okay and it wasn't something that you
just you know you fill with this ghost
and you're humping and jumping and that
it was something that you took a you
know uh this is something that
stimulated your mind is it right right
so now how do you communicate do you
still have some friends who are in that
lifestyle
you still try to communicate to them so
for those people who are out there who
are still
living that kind of like hedonistic
lifestyle they don't want to talk about
anything unless there's girls boys in
the you know
party party any what time how do you
communicate to them
well we're all going to die that's
inevitable
and we're all going to be judged
let's say i'm totally wrong let's say
i'm totally wrong
well at least i'm living a righteous
life and i'm doing good deeds and i'm
taking care of my family and my friends
let's say i am right and that there is
only one god
which i know for a fact there is and
that we are going to be judged
then i'm happy to be on this side
because this is the path
the straight path
guide us to the straight path and all
praises of god
you know all it takes is a little
sincerity all it takes is asking
yourself
alone in your room on the ground
ask the creator don't ask any creations
ask god that's what allah means allah
means the one god
the only god tell us also
now for the people like you had your
wife present day
who was against that other sister
looking into islam so a lot of people
now when you mention islam
like your parents did oh you're you're
going to blow something up now oh you're
a terrorist now
so people they get nervous they get
scared to come out and even to
see to go beyond this courage finding
the courage to to move forward
so for the people that have many
misconceptions a lot of misconceptions a
lot of people fighting the truth
so for those people that think okay
islam oppresses women islam is about
terrorism
islam is you know backwards barbaric
now that you've studied it you've sat
with scholars you've sat with people
you know and you've learned it what do
you have to say for those people we
don't have so much time to go over and
we've covered a lot of this in other
shows
what do you have for those people that
might have this on their mind
well you know just like nike says just
do it
and that's just what i did whenever i
don't want to do it i just do it
and my recommendation would be just to
pray
you know sit down and take a moment
personally i'm 24 years old
eddie i wish somebody would have told me
about islam
a long time ago because i've never felt
this kind of peace
period yeah the end simple
yeah so any now okay you went to hajj
you're praying five times a day uh tell
us a little bit more before we close how
just you know how's it benefit benefited
your life and some of the
the other things that you know you do in
life so
people you know you see it's not a big
deal being a muslim it's something that
it's a big deal because you got paradise
in store it's
the true way of life that one needs to
live
to please the creator of the heavens
deserve because if you're submitting to
god you're doing god's will
that's the way god's going to be pleased
with you and it's it's something that
that brings that when you have
peace happiness contentment not
worshiping
the creation not living a paganistic
lifestyle
just doing good and good defined by what
god
says is good so now you know we talked
about prayer we talked about
uh you did the hajj and what else i mean
have your parents seen your character
get better yeah are you more
you know being more kind are you more
conscious of god now yeah uh
absolutely always i was always kind of
greedy because i was i always had
you know i was making good money i never
really treated my folks the right way
my friends you know i don't know what
they would have said about back me back
in the day
now my i help my family with their bills
you know they're struggling i try to
help them out i try to do good deeds and
what i love about islam is
i always have god on my mind whether i
open the door for somebody
my intention is always in my heart i say
before i do a good deed
my intention is to please god and that's
what's important eddie
just always trying to please god and
having that conscious
of god at all times knowing that i'm
going to be judged
and you know whether it be like somebody
some a billboard on the side of the road
or something on tv
now i'll cover my eyes whenever i see
something that i should
you know we know we shouldn't be looking
at and it feels good to do good
because when you do good what happens it
breeds good it breeds good
yeah well thank you very much for being
with us justin peace be with you brother
please be with you thank you thank you
very much and that was another person's
story on how they came
to the way of life that's not organized
by
man or men but it's organized by the
creator
of men by the creator of women the one
god the god that jesus
worship we're all gonna die you heard
our guests give you some good advice
think about death think about that
moment
when it's all over it's finished kaput
and you gotta leave all the material
things behind
where you're going when you die islam
tells you the purpose of life
why you've been created islam tells you
everything you need to do
to be successful in this life and islam
is not calling you to hurt innocent
men women and children it's not calling
you to all these things that
some people will try to peak king pepe
king will try to have you
believe no islam is calling you to
goodness and good
breeds good and it's all built on the
bedrock the bedrock
of worshipping the one god the same god
that jesus worshiped
that's the god that you worship nobody
else and if you want to read the
verbatim word of god
it's free give us a call 1-800-662 in
islam
and until next time we'll see you peace
be unto you